we don't often talk about Nobel Prize
winners on the show but I have to today
because this year's Nobel Prize in
Economics is directly about one of the
huge problems of economics today and if
you watched or listened to the show last
week I interviewed economist Steve keen
and he explained to us different ways in
which economics is falling short in
explaining how the world actually works
and it leads to totally destructive
policy if you don't understand the
basics of how economics works and then
you make policy based on those
misunderstandings you're gonna have a
bad time you're gonna make really bad
decisions one item one term that Steve
Kean mentioned and that I've talked
about is externalities specifically
negative externalities one of the
biggest areas where economics has not
been able to really account for the
negative externalities of our economic
system is when it comes to the
environment and when it comes to climate
change and this year I am sad that this
is so important that it won the nobel
prize in economics but also happy that
it's getting attention
the economics Nobel Prize this year was
split by William Nordhaus and Paul Romer
now Paul Romer looked at calculating the
impact of technological advancement
economically which is very interesting
in and of itself but what I want to
focus in on today is the work of William
Nordhaus
what he has done is to pioneer assessing
the economic impact of climate change
and there are two sort of major problems
right now with convincing governments
and corporations and people to take
climate change really seriously not just
I'm gonna recycle and I'm gonna get the
Prius instead of the SUV that's great
and it would be lovely if everybody did
that and I know Pat is doing all of
those things but if you truly understand
the degree of the problem here you see
that there's a totally missing actual
commitment from governments and
corporations to solve the problem
problem one is lack of a full assessment
of what will the economic impact be of
climate change right that lets people be
in denial because we've not had good
assessments of what are the total what's
the full scope of those negative
analogies it's easier for people to bury
their head in the sand to look the other
way and to say well it's going to be
fixed problem two has been the
assumption that even if we could figure
out what we need to do to deal with
climate change that it's just going to
be too expensive for governments for
companies it's going to be too annoying
to individuals which is insane because
if you think the solution is too
expensive you're admitting the problems
really bad right because if the solution
were not expensive it must be because
the problem is not that bad you're
implicitly acknowledging the scope of
the problem when you say it's just going
to be too expensive
I don't want to set my heat to 55 in the
middle of winter I don't want to bike to
work or whatever
so what Nordhaus did is he developed a
system from the ground up it's a model
which lets economists analyze the costs
of climate change and those models now
are the underpinning of a new United
Nations report on the dangers of climate
change which by the way are sky-high
one take away from Nord House's historic
work is that governments charging people
for polluting is a good idea Nord house
was an early adopter of carbon taxes now
it's not the solution but it's something
that in the short term can be done
the biggest takeaway of the work of
William Nordhaus is that the market has
failed the market has failed we hear
from so-called climate sceptics and free
marketers marketeers I don't know what
the right term is that the markets going
to take care of climate change before it
gets really bad what we have in mind for
really bad is probably out of a science
fiction movie before it gets quote
really bad naturally incentives will
surface in the market and corporations
and private industry are going to fix
the problem the big conclusion from Nord
House's work which by now should be
obvious to all of us is the market has
failed the market has failed Nordhaus
says climate change is a result of the
greatest market failure the world has
seen just because Boston's not yet
underwater even if in ten years were
able to build a system of dams to
prevent Boston from going underwater the
market has already failed because it's
getting worse
worse and worse if the market was
incentivized to solve this problem we
wouldn't be where we are now
yeah the neoclassical view on economics
isn't holding up here and I think that's
why you'll have to see people on their
right moving the goalposts it's not any
longer that the market will solve this
problem it's just that this problem
doesn't exist that climate change isn't
happening and that certainly man isn't
causing it the explanations are becoming
more and more unhinged from the sceptics
because we're too far past now to go
back
we have mounting expertise from
economists that as a starting point
I mean carbon taxes are just a must do
instead of subsidizing oil and other
fossil fuels we should be taxing the use
of those fossil fossil fuels and then
subsidizing the development of
alternatives and the use of alternatives
but the problem is that the carbon taxes
we would need to actually stop the
advancement of this problem are
ridiculously high like an IPCC estimate
says we ultimately will need 27 thousand
dollars per ton in carbon taxes the
Trump administration says that the total
social cost is $7 per tonne IPCC says we
need the tax carbon at 27 K per ton
Trump says we really only have seven
dollars worth of social costs per ton so
we know that in the end carbon taxes
aren't going to solve this we know that
the market has already failed to solve
it
we're gonna need regulation plain and
simple and the right says it's
politicized no it's pointing out the
reality of the situation and the reality
is that we're in huge trouble and that's
why it's depressing but I'm glad to have
the opportunity to tell you about the
literally Nobel prize-winning work that
is being done on this issue of climate
change I want to hear from you about
this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
quick break we will be back after this
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink accom slash Pakman if you've not
already heard about blink Asst it's
amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get
all the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good
also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudoscience
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a 7 day free trial
by going to blink as comm slash Pakman
if you're watching on youtube use the
link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be Li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n